would your bubbly with your pumping I
know the big scary world it's okay you
want to be on camera
huh come on everyone to see how pretty
you are you want a pig in a blanket no
you want to go get a blanket good girl
digitally oh no you can chew you always
like freezes up 150 like how much boom
it's okay feel good puppy
okay hi guys this is chica and chica is
the newest addition to the family
she is an adorable adorable Golden
Retriever I think she's just under a
year old and she's a little nervous
right now
she's obviously new place new house new
people big smelly Ryan behind the camera
over there didn't like him a lot didn't
even come near him yeah thanks Brian
sober she you know she's uh she's just
been a sweetheart though because she is
amazing and I love her to death and I'm
so happy to be able to have a dog now
and I know that like my life is gonna
change I'm gonna walk her like five
times a day I'm gonna get up early so
that she's fed right on schedule out for
a morning and then go out poop
everywhere you can pee wherever you want
wherever you want wherever you would in
the whole world yeah so she's uh she's
getting used to everything in a few days
she'll be a little more acclimated
right now she's calling because I fed
her tons of food I gave her all the love
in the world lots of snacks cooing here
oh oh hey oh you're going up to big
smelly Ryan oh she likes smelly she's
warming up to you she's like wood
okay come on come on hey Tom Becca I'm
back here judging kupo
here's another baby no blanket u1j new
yeah so she's a new addition to the
family and she's gonna warm this house
up a whole ton we've been making a lot
of renovations Ryan and Matt have been
working on setting up a projector
apparently it hasn't been going very
well and I keep telling him that a TV
would be just good but you know Ryan has
to have a projector it's got to have
that authentic yes yes shut up
this is not about me what it was about
chica Oh beautiful
yeah so we're gonna have a lot of fun
and you're gonna see way too much of
chica you'll eat sick of her with how
many photos and videos set up in a post
of her and just in general she is going
to make life a lot happier
so that's chica do you bye bye ok bye
bye Kiki boom we get everybody you
wanted to the freaking blanket are you
actually coming up to say hi
yet don't you google what you go in see
beautiful kids
oh pretty
not me not you I'm pretty uh yeah too
pretty
wait I just want to like oh that's
beautiful take some pics take some pics
it's okay